russian elections are rigged  political opponents  are imprisoned or otherwise eliminated  from participating in the electoral  process  the result is an absence of checks and  balances in russia and the decision of  one man  to launch a wholly unjustified  and brutal invasion of iraq i mean of  ukraine  all right anyway  75  the truth of the matter is  our system works pretty well  we've got a large complicated country  with a variety of different uh interests  and states and yet uh we've been pulling  off elections for quite a while the  ballot is stronger than the bullet  pretty relevant these days  i hear a lot about uh  today's political environment  a lot of angst around the country people  are really worried they don't like the  anger they don't like the finger  pointing they expect better  and uh and if you got a problem with  that the key thing is to vote